[Music]
ever tried a diy project and found
yourself yelling di why
did i try this
do-it-yourself expert jenny yolo has
some helpful tips
you want to dip it in brush it off a few
times
we're going to start in this corner
and go at a 45 degree angle
and start our dashes
i like to stay close to the line but not
necessarily hit it that way
you won't get a cut off dash
okay it looks really good not perfect
that's what you want
and now i'm going to do the other side
so
i like to match up
so it creates almost an arrow
all right one down and i'm gonna finish
the rest of the wall now
we're gonna skip this one that we use as
a guide and this one's gonna be the new
center of our arrow so we'll start
going down on this side and then we'll
do the reflection on this side
and now we're done
now we're gonna pull off the tape
the painted wall treatment is done and i
brought everything into this room i just
love how the design
ties it all together
great tip chip and joanna where can we
watch mo jenny well she hosts the
handcrafted home projects workshop on
the magnolia app where you can learn how
to make unique items for your home
oh diy not
[Music]